Bongo woke up early on the day of the Animal Olympics.
He was very excited.
He was sure he could win a gold medal.
The Animal Olympics were being held at the zoo.
All the young animals were invited to compete in the games.
The first event was running.
Bongo thought he was a good runner.
He was sure he would win the race.
The animals lined up at the starting line.
"Ready, set, go!",...
...yelled the starter.
Bongo had only run three steps when the winner reached the finish line.
The cheetah won.
Bongo was last.
Bongo was not worried.
There were still five events left.
He would win the next event, the long jump.
He was a great jumper.
He was sure he would win the long jump.
Bongo did not even reach the sandpit.
The kangaroo jumped to the end of the sandpit.
The kangaroo was the winner.
Bongo was last.
Bongo was not worried.
There were still four events left.
He would win the next event, swimming.
He was a great swimmer.
He was sure he would win the swimming race.
Bongo had only swum three strokes when the winner reached the end of the pool.
The dolphin was the winner.
Bongo was last.
Bongo was not worried.